[Música]
hola me llamo giuseppe mi plato favorito
es la pasta a la carbonara me diréis
este va a hablar de proteínas
alternativas y me cuenta que le gusta la
pasta a la carbonara pues sí la verdad
que a nueve de cada diez personas de
media nos gusta la carne y eso puede ser
un problema el problema que es
insostenible
voy contar dos historias dos historias
que tratan los anfibios el primero una
rana
si una rana cae en aguas termales y
detecta que el agua termal está
alrededor de 90 a 100 grados salta
inmediatamente fuera del agua porque
sabe que su vida está en peligro
porque detecta un cambio de temperatura
inmediato en su cerebro detecta que hay
un cambio que es peligroso para su salud
y salta afuera de la del agua termal
pero en experimentos si se subía la
temperatura poco a poco el cerebro de la
rana no era capaz de entender que su
vida estaba en peligro y no había
escapatoria para la rana en realidad
este gráfico no es del experimento de
badana sino es el cambio de temperatura
en los últimos 170 años en el planeta
nosotros como es las ganas sí nos
estamos enfrente a una crisis inmediata
nuestro cerebro no se da cuenta que
estamos en frente de un problema muy
grave
el problema que actualmente definiendo
como la sexta extinción de masa y esta a
diferencia de las demás está causada por
el ser humano
causada por el hombre
hay dos problemas principales uno como
en el caso de la temperatura del gráfico
que hemos visto antes el caso del
problema de la temperatura creciente
calentamiento global y otro que me
preocupa a mí personalmente muchísimo es
el colapso de la biodiversidad es debido
en gran parte a pérdida del hábitat
natural donde los animales están
viviendo por ejemplo este vídeo enseña
como en brasil gran parte del bosque de
las amazonas en los últimos 20-30 años
ha sido destruido por hacer espacio para
sobre todo tierra para la carne en este
gráfico el primer causante
gases de efecto invernadero en brasil
debido a la deforestación en la carne
cual es el segundo problema pues no
importa es tan grave la carne que los
demás asociados a la deforestación no
importan son tan pequeños el efecto que
tienen comparado con la carne de vacuno
sobre todo este otro gráfico enseña el
efectos de la carne sobre él
sobre la deforestación podemos ver por
ejemplo en este gráfico que el 25 por
ciento de la deforestación es debida
sólo a carne de brasil es increíble un
cuarto de la deforestación del mundo no
sólo está invertir sino expida la carne
los otros son carnes que vienen de otras
partes de latinoamérica y después de
otras partes del mundo el segundo
problema
7 de palma
las hojas que se usan normalmente no
para uso humano sino las hojas el
problema es cuando se usa o para
combustibles o para comida para los
animales
entonces esos datos son para demostrar
como la rana que no nos damos cuenta que
hay problemas que están llegando y que
son simplemente graduales y nuestro
cerebro no está entrenado no está en
nuestro adn entender problemas que pasan
a lo largo a lo largo de décadas
el segundo problema que estaba en el
gráfico el segundo causante de la
deforestación era el aceite de palma y
el aceite debido a la soja y la soja que
se usa para la comida para los animales
este por ejemplo el caso de borneo
podéis ver que es un desastre en el cual
en los últimos 70 años hemos destruido
completamente el borneo
este es un bosque milenario como los que
veis aquí o bosques millonarios que no
se puede regenerar esto no se puede
regenerar plantando árboles hay una
biodiversidad y una mezcla de vegetación
que no es posible crear que la creamos
en nosotros como ser humano y
replanteando árboles es un problema que
es irreversible a mí nunca me han
gustado las cosas irreversibles os
cuento la segunda historia de un anfibio
este anfibio se llama ajolote es un
anfibio muy especial es una afición
especial porque sabe regenerar casi todo
su cuerpo si le dejamos con su corazón y
su cabeza es capaz de regenerar mejor
que la salamandra mejor que los
lagartijas es capaz de regenerarse
incluso si le cortamos gran parte de su
cuerpo a mí nunca me han gustado las
cosas irreversibles y entonces cuando
era pequeño me gustaba el ambiente la
biomedicina sobre todo asociada al
deporte pensaba los atletas los atletas
de élite es que se rompen un ligamento
un tendón no pueden volver nunca a jugar
como antes entonces las cosas
irreversible me me preocupaban y
descubrí este animal
este animal quedan sólo cuatro mil de
ellos en
libertad 4000
en todo el mundo
el animal ajolote me empujó a estudiar
un tema que es el tema de la
bioingeniería entonces yo estudié en
varios países y después decisión
doctoral después se fue por un periodo
profesor en barcelona- de bioingeniería
en específico de ingeniería de tejidos
me especialicé en regenerar órganos y
partes del cuerpo órganos y tejidos
normalmente para uso biomédico también
podía ser para uso veterinario y me
especialicé en usar
materiales bio materiales sobre todo de
origen natural para evitar las cosas
irreversibles saber regenerar el cuerpo
es algo increíble verdad sabe regenerar
el cuerpo y conseguir trabajar con
grupos de investigación tan buenos que
llegamos a hacer ensayos clínicos para
córnea artificial en piel artificial
conseguimos trabajar en cartílago en
hueso en músculo y después me
especialicé
y llegué a pensar de ser uno de los
mejores del mundo en un campo específico
que era el campo de la bio impresión una
técnica muy avanzada de bioingeniería
que permite de crear con impresión 3d
pero creando microfilamentos con
biomateriales tejidos y órganos muy
complejos que podían ser como en este
caso no funcionales estar un prototipo
de oreja humana pero que podía llegar a
ser muy útiles para en los próximos años
regenerar el cuerpo del ser humano
pero después como la rana
menos mal la temperatura subió un poco
demasiado deprisa y me di cuenta de dos
cosas en los últimos años vi como uno de
los últimas especies de rinocerontes
desde parecía dedique noticias que el
50% del consumo de proteína en los
próximos cuatro años ya no va a ser de
europa de eeuu sino que va a ser en
india y en china donde la clase media
necesita es creciente acceso a proteína
y es un desastre porque no tenemos
bastante para dar de comer a tantas
personas
entonces llegué a entender como si
hubiera caído como una rana cayendo en
un charco de un agua termal que
estábamos en frente a lo que se llama el
colapso de la biodiversidad
y esto es irreversible si se pierde una
especie no sabemos cómo
entonces pensé por qué tantas personas
hacen hamburguesas vegetales pero si el
80% de los que comen carne
lo que quieren es cortes fibrosos los
datos dicen en europa en eeuu que el 80
por ciento de la venta de carne el
supermercado no son hamburguesas
albóndigas o dawson o carne que no es
estructurada como tiras de pollo o
trozos de atún sino que son bistec
solomillos filetes pechugas de pollo no
tenemos una alternativa para eso y pensé
porque nadie lo hace y descubrí que era
un problema tecnológico nadie era capaz
de hacer un corte fibroso de carne con
un bistec y pensé quién mejor que los
ingenieros de tejidos que trabajamos en
regenerar órganos porque en vez de
regenerar órganos para uso humano
hacemos algo para el planeta y
regeneramos un trozo de carne un trozo
de músculo los empecé a estudiar el
músculo y hice prototipos de principio
que no eran muy espectaculares eran el
prototipo es un poco para demostrar que
la tecnología funcionaba pero lo
importante como explicaré al final
la curiosidad entre otras cosas que nos
empuja a ser cosas un poco nuevas
incluso raras entonces cree en 2018 el
primer bistec vegetal impreso en 3d del
mundo
pero no sólo era el primer bistec letal
en presente del mundo era el primer
corte fibroso de carne vegetal
entonces con un poco de trabajo y
gracias que había trabajado diez años en
tejidos y ya había trabajado muchos años
en laboratorio y en regeneración de
órganos conseguir juntarme con con
johann al principio y llegamos a tener
bastante suerte en
recibimos tracción mediática y ya ha
perdido el periodo de principio los
periodistas los curiosos los grandes
chefs se acercaron y preguntaron qué
estás haciendo entonces descubrimos que
la industria y las personas y los
gobiernos que estaban preocupados para
la resiliencia de su sistema de comida y
también estaban preocupados porque no
querían importar más carne y depender de
la carne importada entonces
vimos que vimos que la necesitaba lo que
es una alternativa a la carne fibrosa
entonces con johann empezamos a trabajar
en prototipos ya un poco más avanzados y
utilizamos una adaptación de la bio
impresión que yo usaba antes con un
sistema que la he desarrollado para
imprimir chocolate y juntos creamos
modelos como este que ha sido
considerado el bistec vegetal más
realista del mundo
en 2020 por el guardián y otras revistas
importantes y después pensamos ir un
poco más allá y pensamos no existe carne
de cerdo fibrosa en el mundo sólo se
consigue imitar carne picada de cerdo y
entonces con johann conseguimos a crear
el primer corte de carne libros o de
cerdo del mundo es la misma proyecta que
estamos imprimiendo y cocinando aquí
y después pensamos ir más allá
y construimos la pieza más grande del
mundo celular
que podéis ver en pantalla era y es
todavía la pieza más grande del mundo de
corte fibroso de carne celular o sea
mezclando no solo ingredientes de origen
vegetal sino también células en
específico trabajamos con células madres
es lo que yo he trabajado durante muchos
años cuando conseguía e intentaba
construir órganos del laboratorio y
entonces salimos también
reconocidos por este nuevo logro
y por último pensamos lo importante es
el impacto no solo hacerlo con impresora
3d para hacer algo superior espectacular
sino se necesita tener un impacto y
producirlo en escala y este año en 2021
conseguimos producir con cada una de las
máquinas no son estas máquinas una
máquinas mucho más grandes no las
llamaría impresora 3d persona adaptación
de nuestra tecnología conseguimos con
una técnica llamada micro extrusión
digamos crear una tonelada a la hora de
estos productos al principio empezamos
con productos como este que son cortes
fibrosos de hoy o esto no tiene soja por
ejemplo tienen guisante amarillento que
no solo está hecho muy rápido sino que
además se puede utilizar una variedad de
ingredientes para que los consumidores
pueden elegir qué cuál es la los
siguientes los valores nutricionales que
quieran después empezamos a trabajar con
mejores chefs del mundo y pensamos no
queremos crear un coche eléctrico que
vaya muy lento y queremos crear un coche
eléctrico que acelera de 0 a 100 en dos
segundos para que se uno lo compara con
un coche normal de petróleo diga este
eléctrico es incluso mejor que lo que
cuesta un millón de euros y es un coche
digamos tradicional entonces pensamos en
varias estrategias para con nuestro
proyecto contribuir a lo que es la
salvaguardia del planeta en particular
para terminar mi charla os voy a
comentar que hay cuatro cosas que se
pueden hacer si alguien quiere
contribuir de forma muy activa muy
directa para salvar el planeta
la primera no está asociada con las
alternativas de forma muy directa y son
las energías renovables obviamente hay
que pasar transitar de ahora o después
no es cuestión de cuándo sino de
cuestión de si sino de cuándo entonces
tenemos que ser lo antes posible la
verdad utilizar a lo mejor la energía
geotermal la energía del sol y las otras
tres de las cuatro ideas para salvar el
planeta de las más directas son
asociadas a las proteínas alternativas
evitar la sobrepesca estableciendo zonas
de no pesca donde se pueda regenerar el
sistema del océano pueda revivir y esto
se puede solucionar con alternativa al
pescado podemos hacer con agricultura o
incluso con cultivos de algas
alternativas a la proteína de pescado
también
segundo se puede también se tiene que
pasar a transición hacia una dieta
probablemente mente vegetal esto habéis
visto en los datos que he enseñado hasta
ahora es fundamental para evitar la
deforestación y la destrucción de la
biodiversidad y por último la
deforestación hay que pagarla de
inmediato a uno puede gustarle la carne
puede no gustarle la carne puede
importarle o no el efecto que tiene
sobre la salud puede importarle o no el
efecto que tiene sobre el bienestar
animal pero nadie quiere reforestar el
planeta nadie quiere destruir lo que
tenemos de lo más importante de nuestra
nuestra tierra
a mi sueño y ahora tengo un niño de un
año que se llama marko es que los
próximos años consigamos
regenerar restablecer y volver otra vez
a tener partes muy grandes del planeta
que podamos dejar libres para la
biodiversidad porque cuando usamos
cuando usan proteínas alternativas y no
usamos la carne recuperamos muchísima
tierra
el 77% de todas las tierras arables del
planeta se usa para la ganadería
es mucho menos eficiente alrededor de 50
veces más eficiente en términos de
tierra y alrededor del
95% sería más eficiente en términos de
agua de huella de carbono por lo tanto
es algo que es muy simple hay que
trabajar y conseguir alternativas
y por último último dejar una idea
porque a alguien le puede gustar este
proyecto un proyecto parecido las
portillas alternativas hacer algo para
el planeta o le gusta hacer algo para su
familia o algo para su digamos la
sociedad en general lo importante es
tener un proyecto en el que estamos
mejorando las cosas y las cuatro cosas
que se pueden hacer la más importante es
la curiosidad la curiosidad es se puede
entrenar es lo fundamental para
cualquier proyecto y para por ejemplo
salvar el planeta lo segundo es la
valentía tenemos poco tierra poco tiempo
en esta en este planeta
podemos hacer que cuenten tercero la
constancia no nos podemos rendir
en una ocasión no funciona
inmediatamente no importa lo que diga
los demás lo cuarto la confianza en sí
mismo tenemos tan poco tiempo si decimos
algo que pensamos que es bueno podemos
pedir consejo pero hay que ser seguros
de sí y seguir adelante
y ahora vamos a probar hemos hecho en 15
minutos
allí tenéis que estamos cocinando dos
brochetas de cerdo esto de proteína
vegetal esto si lo hacéis con animales
no podéis en diez minutos crecer un
animal y comerlo
habéis entendido que es una manera mucho
más eficiente porque se usa de la
proteína vegetal no se tiene que pasar
al animal que es un motor muy poco
eficiente y después pasar a comerlo sino
en 16 minutos hemos creado carne de
proteínas vegetales y esto sí que tiene
la textura la apariencia el sabor y las
propiedades nutricionales para sustituir
la carne
así que si quieres comemos
si quieres 20 y cómo será proyectado
graves estatus para enseñar que estás
comestibles
y ya después nos vamos porque el
ventanal y otro también
nos vamos a ir pero por último os
dejamos los créditos o títulos de cola
estas son las especies del planeta de
los cuales quedan solo mil ejemplares
puedes darle al play de este vídeo
porfavor abajo debería haber el botón
del play
perfecto pues nos vamos mirar la lista
de los títulos de cola que nos empujan a
hacer algo para el planeta